Générique
- Kathia Gilder: Bonjour.
Bienvenue sur le plateau
de "Parlement hebdo".
Les moments forts de l'Assemblée
nationale et du Sénat,
avec vous, Alexandre.
- Alexandre Poussart: Nous sommes
avec Hervé Marseille, sénateur des
Hauts-de-Seine
et président de l'UDI.
- Kathia Gilder: Il y a beaucoup
d'actualité pour vous, à commencer
par les trois semaines d'examen
au Sénat, mais avec un nouveau
passage en force du budget 2023,
adopté sans vote, jeudi.
Les énergies renouvelables
au menu des députés.
Débat électrique sur la question
des éoliennes.
Débat sur l'immigration, au
Parlement, en attendant le projet
de loi.
Le gouvernement a exposé les
grandes lignes de son futur texte,
notamment l'accélération des
procédures d'expulsion.
- Alexandre Poussart: Le
gouvernement a encore utilisé le
49.3 pour faire passer le budget,
après trois semaines d'examen au
Sénat, où le texte a été remanié
en profondeur.
- L'exécutif dégaine un nouveau
49.3 sur le budget, à l'Assemblée.
C'est la huitième fois de
sa mandature que le gouvernement
engage sa responsabilité.
Reste à savoir ce qu'il gardera
des modifications du Sénat.
Mardi, après un record de 2500
amendements, la chambre haute
a adopté un budget 2023 largement
remanié, pour défendre les moyens
des collectivités locales face à
la crise.
Exemple avec la CVAE, la taxe sur
la valeur ajoutée des entreprises
qui bénéficie aux collectivités
et que le gouvernement
veut supprimer.
Une suppression rejetée
par le Sénat.
- Il reste deux grands sujets.
La suppression de la CVAE, que
vous avez voulu supprimer.
Nous proposerons,
à l'Assemblée nationale,
de rétablir
la suppression de la CVAE.
J'ai compris que nous pouvions
aller plus loin et être plus
clairs sur les modalités de
compensation pour
les collectivités.
- Le Sénat a dressé plusieurs
lignes rouges, comme sur le filet
de sécurité qui doit aider
face à l'augmentation des factures
énergétiques.
Les sénateurs ont assoupli les
critères pour que toutes les
communes puissent en bénéficier.
Ils ont aussi supprimé le pacte
de confiance du gouvernement, qui
obligeait les collectivités
à contenir la hausse de leurs
dépenses sous peine de sanctions.
Inacceptable pour les sénateurs,
qui redoutent que le gouvernement
supprime leurs modifications.
- Ma crainte est que ce soit un
signe supplémentaire de cette
fatigue démocratique, de cette
crise institutionnelle.
Le gouvernement ne peut pas
balayer trop rapidement les
apports et réflexions du Sénat.
Il faut que le gouvernement
entende la voix des territoires.
- Le texte doit revenir
en seconde lecture au Sénat,
mais face au blocage entre
la chambre haute et l'exécutif,
les sénateurs pourraient décider
de ne même pas discuter
une dernière fois le budget
en rejetant l'ensemble du projet
de loi de finances
avant même un nouvel examen.
- Alexandre Poussart: Un nouveau
49.3 dégainé par Elisabeth Borne.
Le gouvernement banalise-t-il le
passage en force?
- Hervé Marseille: Il n'y a pas
de discussion.
On passe des jours et des soirées
à examiner des textes budgétaires,
à voter, mais on a l'impression
de faire du vélo d'appartement.
On pédale sans avancer d'un
centimètre, puisque le gouvernement
dit que ça ne sert à rien
et explique ce qu'il va se passer.
On a l'impression que le
gouvernement n'a pas compris qu'il
n'avait plus de majorité à
l'Assemblée nationale, qu'il
fallait travailler avec l'ensemble
des forces politiques.
Il ne le fait pas.
- Kathia Gilder: C'est son droit,
d'utiliser le 49.3
autant de fois qu'il le veut
sur un texte budgétaire uniquement.
C'est ce qu'il va faire.
Mais cela affaiblit-il la
démocratie?
- Hervé Marseille: Vous l'avez
dit, à partir du moment où
il utilise une arme prévue par la
Constitution, on ne peut pas
le lui reprocher.
Mais un gouvernement qui veut
essayer de trouver des solutions
majoritaires, ça va lui rendre
les choses compliquées.
Pour les retraites,
il va falloir parler.
On ne peut pas mettre du 49.3
à toutes les sauces.
- Kathia Gilder: Politiquement,
c'est plus compliqué,
mais il le peut?
- Hervé Marseille: Il n'y en a
plus qu'un.
Sur quels textes vont-ils utiliser
ce joker?
Et après?
Il faudra trouver une majorité.
Si le gouvernement continue à
pratiquer le blocage, comment
va-t-il pouvoir agir, une fois
qu'il n'aura plus le 49.3?
C'est la grande question de 2023.
- Alexandre Poussart:
Le gouvernement va-t-il conserver
quelques apports du Sénat?
Vous avez des garanties sur la
protection des collectivités
territoriales?
- Hervé Marseille: Aucune.
Il était prévu que le gouvernement
avance sur les propositions faites
au Sénat pour les collectivités
territoriales, en particulier,
il s'était engagé à renoncer au
contrat de confiance,
aux sanctions à l'égard des
collectivités qui étaient
supposées dépenser trop.
C'est une mission de tutelle.
Il n'y a plus d'autonomie des
collectivités territoriales.
L'essentiel des recettes
provient de l'Etat.
En plus, on applique des
sanctions.
Les collectivités sont corsetées.
Le gouvernement a le choix entre
aider les collectivités et les
entreprises.
On aide beaucoup les entreprises.
Donc, ils font le choix d'aider
les entreprises, en disant que
c'est un impôt de production
et ils le suppriment.
Il va rester quoi?
- Alexandre Poussart: Si
le gouvernement ne retient aucune
modification du Sénat, êtes-vous
favorable à un rejet du texte
sans examen?
- Hervé Marseille:
C'est ce qui va se passer.
On ne va pas perdre encore une
semaine à discuter d'un texte pour
lequel on va simplement nous dire
comment nous passer
de ce dont on a besoin.
On va gagner du temps.
- Kathia Gilder: Une question
plus politique: la majorité au Sénat
est composée des LR et de vous,
centristes, mais dans ce débat
budgétaire, il semble que vous ayez
pris un peu vos distances
avec vos collègues LR, notamment
pour rejeter la suppression de la
CVAE, l'impôt sur les entreprises
perçu par les collectivités,
ou pour défendre l'idée d'une taxe
sur les superprofits.
Est-ce que les différences
se creusent avec la majorité?
Vous prenez le large par rapport
aux idées de vos collègues LR?
- Hervé Marseille: On peut aussi
dire qu'ils s'écartent de nos
idées.
Il y a une référence qui serait
les choix de LR et les nôtres?
Non.
Il y a une majorité, des compromis
qui sont discutés, ce qu'on fait
de façon naturelle, sous
l'autorité de Gérard Larcher, mais
quand il y a des différences,
on les assume.
Les LR sont de droite
et ils passent leurs journées à se
demander de quel droit ils vont
se nantir, une fois passé leur
congrès.
C'est normal qu'il y ait des
différences.
Nous sommes au centre.
Quand on a des positions
et qu'elles ne sont pas les mêmes,
on les assume.
Sur la CVAE,
on refuse sa suppression.
A la dernière minute,
nos collègues LR ont
préféré faire un choix différent.
C'est un impôt de production qui
pèse sur les entreprises.
"On va peut-être accepter la
moitié de la suppression."
Non, ce n'est pas ce qu'on a
défini ensemble.
- Alexandre Poussart: Vous pensez
que le dialogue avec LR
se passe moins bien depuis des mois
alors qu'ils sont en campagne
pour la présidence du parti
et que la droite se durcit?
- Hervé Marseille: Ca se passe
bien globalement.
Quand il y a une campagne interne
chez LR, et dans tous les partis,
puisque le PS, le PCF,
les Verts, même le RN,
il y a aussi des élections internes,
forcément, il y a
une grille de lecture
qui impacte les textes.
Chez nos amis LR,
il y a une compétition
entre différents candidats.
Cela impacte
la lecture des textes.
- Kathia Gilder: L'Assemblée a
donné le coup d'envoi du débat sur
les énergies renouvelables.
Un projet de loi destiné à combler
le retard français en termes
de panneaux solaires et d'éoliennes.
C'est l'un des points
de crispation du débat.
- Le mot ne figure même plus dans
le projet de loi, mais ce sont
bien les éoliennes qui ont
cristallisé les débats.
A droite et à l'extrême droite,
on aimerait que soit instauré un
droit de veto pour les maires,
soit imposer un moratoire.
- Il faut que nos compatriotes
sachent ce qui se joue avec ce
texte.
C'est le déploiement d'éoliennes
sur l'équivalent de 1%
du territoire national.
- On est là pour être le dernier
rempart envers ceux qui défendent
ce qu'on a de plus cher au monde:
nos paysages, notre France!
- La ministre
de la Transition énergétique
ne peut que constater
l'hostilité des LR et du RN
contre son projet de loi.
- C'est un refus de développer
les énergies renouvelables.
Assumez-le!
Ce n'est pas un problème.
Assumez que vous ne voulez pas
d'indépendance énergétique pour
notre pays!
Assumez que vous ne voulez pas
développer de l'électricité
bas carbone!
Assumez que vous préférez laisser
les Français dans le noir demain,
plutôt que de sortir
des énergies fossiles!
- C'est donc vers la partie gauche
de l'hémicycle que le gouvernement
compte se tourner
pour obtenir une majorité.
- Avec vous, nous avons trouvé
un dialogue véritable, exigeant,
parfois compliqué, mais constructif,
qui a permis à chacun
d'évoluer sur ce texte.
- Eu égard au chemin parcouru par
ce texte, nous restons attentifs
aux débats.
Nous ne sommes pas à l'abri
de bonnes ou mauvaises surprises.
- Les députés ont encore une
semaine pour examiner le texte,
sur lequel le gouvernement
a exclu la possibilité
de recourir à l'article 49.3.
- Kathia Gilder: Hervé Marseille,
ce droit de veto souhaité par LR
et le RN, les députés que nous
avons vus dans l'hémicycle, est-ce
une bonne idée,
ce droit de veto des maires?
- Hervé Marseille: Non.
Nous l'avons dit.
Je comprends, c'est respectable,
mais c'est plus une posture qu'une
possibilité pour les maires.
Ca les met en difficulté.
Nous avons préféré, ce qui a été
retenu, passer par les documents
de l'urbanisme et par une
planification territoriale, où les
élus sont impliqués.
Mais on fait des zonages pour dire
où c'est possible ou non.
Laisser les maires seuls face à
des entreprises, leur laisser
la seule responsabilité,
ainsi qu'à ceux qui sont
en co-visibilité
sur un territoire,
c'est les exposer
à une responsabilité très forte.
- Alexandre Poussart: A la base,
une partie des sénateurs LR
étaient favorables à ce droit de
veto des maires
sur l'implantation d'éoliennes.
Finalement, il a été abandonné,
sous la pression des sénateurs
centristes.
Est-ce que les LR ont encore une
posture politicienne
sur l'énergie renouvelable?
- Hervé Marseille: Je veux croire
que c'était une idée sincère de
leur part.
Je n'ignore pas qu'au même moment,
il y avait le congrès des maires
qui se réunissait.
Je ne parle pas de coïncidence,
mais il y avait peut-être un lien
de cause à effet.
Aider et défendre les élus, on
peut le faire en ayant des idées
plus subtiles.
Passer par la planification
territoriale, c'est une bonne
chose.
On va voir ce qui va en rester.
A l'Assemblée, ce que j'entends
est un peu préoccupant.
Il y avait un certain nombre de
modifications apportées au texte,
et quelque chose me dit que nous
avons intérêt à agir vite pour
retrouver de l'énergie décarbonée
et d'origine nucléaire.
- Alexandre Poussart: Qu'est-ce
qui vous préoccupe sur les apports
à l'Assemblée?
- Hervé Marseille: Les apports qui
concernent notamment les aspects
visuels sur les territoires, qui
ne sont pas très juridiques.
Ce sont des notions floues, qui
vont laisser la main aux juges.
- Kathia Gilder: Est-ce que vous
faites confiance à ce projet
de loi et aux éoliennes, pour
accélérer la production
d'énergies bas carbone?
- Hervé Marseille: Non.
De toute façon, ce sera compliqué
de construire.
Il faudra prendre beaucoup de
précautions.
C'est normal.
Il ne faut pas défigurer les
paysages et les bords de mer,
comme à La Baule, où il y a eu
des constructions un peu sauvages,
sans tenir compte des élus.
Je crois surtout en l'énergie
nucléaire.
Mais il faut à tout prix...
- Kathia Gilder: Un peu d'éoliennes,
mais on ne compte pas
sur ça pour l'indépendance
énergétique?
- Hervé Marseille: On ne peut pas
stocker l'énergie.
Ce n'est pas demain qu'on va
pouvoir avoir beaucoup d'énergies
renouvelables.
C'est souhaitable,
mais ça va prendre du temps.
- Alexandre Poussart: Vous
succédez à Jean-Christophe Lagarde
à la tête de l'UDI.
Vous êtes dans une alliance
avec le gouvernement ou dans
l'opposition?
- Hervé Marseille: Dans
l'opposition,
mais nous sommes indépendants.
Aujourd'hui, nous sommes
responsables, car, comme d'autres,
nous votons les textes quand
il nous semble qu'il faut voter.
Mais il y a des attentes pour
le pays et la population, qui est en
difficulté.
Il y a le pouvoir d'achat,
l'énergie...
Il y a aussi les problèmes
sociaux.
Il y a beaucoup d'absences
dans le budget sur le logement,
sur la dépendance.
Il y a des angles morts.
Nous sommes dans une position
responsable mais indépendante.
Il n'y a pas de systématisme.
Vous parliez des votes au Sénat.
Il y a une majorité sénatoriale et
une indépendance de notre part.
Nous l'assumons.
- Kathia Gilder: L'alliance
avec les LR a-t-elle de l'avenir?
A quelles conditions?
- Hervé Marseille: Vous pouvez
aussi retourner la question:
est-ce que les LR veulent des
partenaires?
- Kathia Gilder: Comment le
voyez-vous?
- Hervé Marseille: Je vous le
dirai quand nous connaîtrons
la ligne politique définie par la
nouvelle direction des LR.
Ils essaient de définir quel type
de droite va présider
au mouvement.
Une droite niçoise?
Vendéenne?
Je ne sais pas si c'est une droite
qui se referme sur elle-même, qui
regarde sur sa droite,
qui a des partenaires...
J'attends de connaître
un certain nombre de réponses et
d'orientations pour répondre
et nous positionner.
- Alexandre Poussart:
Jean-Christophe Lagarde a été
condamné à 10 mois de prison avec
sursis pour avoir offert un emploi
fictif d'assistante parlementaire
à sa belle-mère.
Cela nuit à l'image
de la politique?
- Hervé Marseille:
Malheureusement, il y a eu pas mal
d'affaires de ce type, qui
correspondaient à une certaine
époque.
Jean-Christophe est un ami, donc
je lui garde mon amitié.
Je déplore toutes ces situations.
Ca n'enlève pas les liens d'amitié
que j'ai pour lui.
J'espère qu'il se tirera d'affaire.
- Alexandre Poussart:
Mardi prochain,
une semaine après les députés,
les sénateurs vont
débattre de la question migratoire,
notamment du projet
que le gouvernement prépare.
Un texte qui prévoit d'accélérer
les procédures d'expulsion
et de régulariser
les travailleurs sans-papiers
et de créer un titre de séjour
pour les métiers en tension.
- La loi sur l'immigration,
c'est non.
Pour plein de raisons.
Il ne s'agit pas de contrôler
l'immigration massive, mais
d'ouvrir un peu plus les vannes.
François Hollande a déjà supprimé
le délit de séjour illégal pour
les clandestins, en 2012.
En réalité, on va plus loin, là,
en annonçant qu'un clandestin
arrivé sur le sol français sera
régularisé automatiquement.
Il y a aussi un deuxième guichet
pour les déboutés
du droit d'asile.
Si on les refuse en termes de
statut de réfugié, ils auront
droit à un second guichet,
celui du travail.
Ce n'est pas un projet de maîtrise
de l'immigration.
- Alexandre Poussart: Pour
les sénateurs centristes, la loi
immigration, c'est oui?
- Hervé Marseille: On va regarder.
J'entends ce que dit Bruno
Retailleau, qui, d'emblée, refuse
le texte.
Moi, j'ai une approche beaucoup
plus pragmatique.
C'est compliqué, les affaires
d'immigration.
D'abord, c'est un texte français,
alors qu'une bonne partie des
solutions sont au niveau européen.
- Kathia Gilder: C'est un domaine
régalien, l'immigration.
- Hervé Marseille: Mais
les frontières sont européennes.
Quand on passe par l'Espagne
ou l'Italie, on va partout.
On connaît les limites des postures
et des coups de menton.
On sait que c'est compliqué
de renvoyer les gens dans les pays
d'origine ou dans les pays
d'accueil où on ne veut plus les
reprendre.
Le Maroc est un pays ami,
et on voit la difficulté.
On essaie de faire pression en
disant: "Tant que vous ne reprenez
pas vos gens qui posent problème
en France, on ne donne plus
de visas."
Ils rigolent et passent par
l'Espagne, qui donne des visas.
Il faut trouver
des solutions européennes.
- Kathia Gilder: Au niveau du
gouvernement français, on a l'idée
de proposer un titre de séjour
pour les métiers en tension,
dans les secteurs
qui peinent à recruter.
C'est une bonne idée?
- Hervé Marseille: Ca se discute.
Ce sont les patrons
qui le demandent.
On sait qu'il y a des métiers
en tension et qu'il y a un tas de
gens qui travaillent dans
des conditions précaires, sans
papiers, que ce soit dans
la restauration, les industries,
notamment touristiques, et on fait
semblant de ne pas regarder ce qui
se passe.
Il y a une logique.
Après, il faut encadrer
et être pragmatique.
Si c'est simplement pour dire "on
va renvoyer les gens chez eux,
on ne laisse plus passer personne
et on ne veut pas accepter les
régularisations", on sait que
ce n'est pas la réalité.
Il y a un débat européen à mener.
Le pacte d'immigration a été lancé
en 2020.
Il patine.
Entre-temps, il y a des dispositifs
de solidarité qui ont
été mis en place.
C'est compliqué.
On le voit,
avec nos amis italiens,
que ce sont toujours les mêmes
qui accueillent:
la France, l'Italie, l'Espagne.
Et on dit aux autres:
"On va partager,
vous allez prendre."
C'est pour ça que
madame Meloni a été élue.
Ils en ont assez d'accueillir
toute la misère du monde.
Il y a aussi le prétexte
des accords de Dublin.
Quand on attrape quelqu'un
sur le sol européen,
par exemple à Calais,
on lui demande
par où il est arrivé.
Il dit: "Par Lampedusa."
On le renvoie à Vintimille
en lui disant:
"Bonne chance. Tu verras,
c'est formidable, l'Italie."
Ca ne peut pas marcher.
Il faut qu'on en parle.
On peut pas rejeter
un texte d'emblée.
On sait que c'est compliqué.
On va examiner avec un avis
plutôt favorable ce texte.
D - Alexandre Poussart: Ca ne va pas
créer un appel d'air migratoire,
comme le disent la droite
et le RN?
- Hervé Marseille: Je veux bien
répondre "à droite toute"
à chaque fois qu'on parle
de domaines régaliens.
Il y a quelqu'un qui est formidable
et qui réussit à tous les coups
dans ce domaine,
c'est madame Le Pen.
S'il y en a une qui récupérera,
c'est elle.
Quand on dit qu'on est
des partis de gouvernement,
qu'un jour on a vocation
à retourner au
gouvernement de ce pays,
on essaie
d'avoir des attitudes
et des propositions réalistes.
Si c'est pour dire la même chose
que madame Le Pen ou monsieur
Zemmour, inutile de se fatiguer.
- Alexandre Poussart: Le LR court
après Marine Le Pen?
- Hervé Marseille: Je ne sais pas.
En tout cas, ils seront jamais
meilleurs que ces deux-là.
- Kathia Gilder: Ce projet de loi
qui sera présenté en février au
Sénat et en mars à l'Assemblée,
il a déjà été repoussé.
Vous pensez qu'il sera
à nouveau repoussé?
- Hervé Marseille: En 2023, il y a
de gros sujets qui seront au coeur
de la réflexion de la vie politique,
pour toutes les
formations politiques
républicaines.
D'abord, comment on fait fonctionner
le Parlement,
puisqu'il n'y a pas de majorité
et qu'il n'y aura plus de 49.3,
à part un seul?
Après les retraites, s'il est
confirmé qu'elles sont discutées
en partie en janvier
sur la mesure d'âge,
ce sera un budget
rectificatif.
On pourra alors utiliser le 49.3.
On doit voir madame Borne
cette semaine.
Mais c'est ce qui est annoncé.
Après, il restera un 49.3.
Je ne sais pas ce que
le gouvernement décidera de faire
avec son 49.3.
Ca peut être pour un autre
dossier, l'immigration,
le travail...
Après, il faudra que le pays
avance, que le Parlement
travaille, qu'il y ait des textes
répondant aux préoccupations des
Françaises et des Français.
C'est la première grande question.
La deuxième, c'est comment
on s'organise politiquement pour
éviter que madame Le Pen devienne
présidente de la République en
2027.
- Alexandre Poussart: Il faut
renforcer une alliance autour
d'Emmanuel Macron pour l'éviter?
- Hervé Marseille:
Je n'ai pas la recette.
C'est compliqué.
Mais ce sont des questions que les
responsables politiques
devront se poser en 2023.
- Alexandre Poussart: Vous parliez
de la réforme des retraites.
Si le gouvernement passe dessus
au 49.3, ce serait acceptable?
- Hervé Marseille: Nous avons
la conviction qu'il faut réformer.
Nous avons d'ailleurs voté
un texte depuis plusieurs années,
au Sénat, un texte équilibré,
avec le départ à 64 ans,
l'accélération des durées
de cotisation et un
travail sur la pénibilité
des carrières longues.
C'est un peu ce qu'il faudrait
trouver à l'arrivée.
Je pense que le gouvernement
pourrait s'en inspirer.
Ca va être une réforme difficile.
On voit que les syndicats et les
Français...
- Kathia Gilder: Vous pensez
qu'ils sont prêts à la réforme?
- Hervé Marseille: Il va falloir
beaucoup de discussion.
Il y a des pistes, en particulier
dans un pays où tout le monde veut
garder la retraite à 60 ans, les
35 heures et la santé gratuite.
Et on s'étonne d'avoir beaucoup
d'impôts.
Si on ne veut pas que
la cotisation soit trop longue,
il faut peut-être toucher
aux 35 heures.
- Alexandre Poussart: On termine
avec l'agenda de la semaine.
- Kathia Gilder: Le moment fort
à l'Assemblée nationale, ce sera la
lecture définitive du budget,
jeudi 15 décembre.
Faute d'accord, le gouvernement
devrait utiliser une ultime fois
l'article 49.3.
- Alexandre Poussart: Merci
d'avoir participé
à cette émission.
Merci de l'avoir suivie.